in the grand scheme of things these
horse is still pretty young
despite that we've seen a lot of players
come and go some ride off with honor
into the sunset some make tearful
farewells to the bittersweet tears of
their fans and some exit quietly looking
to get away from eSports harsh
spotlights but some players do the
opposite some players go out in a blaze
so bright that everybody in the industry
can't help but notice one of the most
notable eSports exit' infernos was
started by former counter logic gaming
midlaner austin election and the fuel
for that fire is now famous dunzo
manifesto links manifesto is a relic
from a time before the franchise na LCS
for most of his career link played for
CLG he was even with the team before the
LCS forum he helped to find clg's
identity over his three years with the
team but there were some struggles
sociology were one of the stronger teams
in na they were never quite able to beat
their deep team solomid and clouded
CLG also had to fight their way out of
relegation White's making them one of
the most inconsistent teams in na
despite their top to your status and
this is gonna be the game
but the LG they make it back into the
North American LCS with a three game
straight being down two games to begin
with this is a success story they were
looking for they've proved that they can
come back GD and eight months after that
relegation run link threw the towel left
the team and penned a farewell letter
the letter itself open with a promise
that link wasn't just gonna straight up
flame people and it started out like any
eSports career Chronicle the blink had a
rampant passion for gaming a tense
relationship with his parents and in the
end had to make a choice between an
education or an eSports career but his
lanes manifesto began delving into his
time on CLG he did actually start to
straight-up play people he flamed his
teammates for they're not practicing and
lack of Independence in game saying that
CLG shotcalling is like babysitting he
even claimed the game itself and how was
played saying that League of Legends is
devolving into a game that I don't even
recognize anymore but more than anything
or anyone link flame doublelift
and his fleeting trust in his teammates
link wrote once doublelift loses respect
for anyone
you're [ __ ] dunzo the vitriolic 17
page long document skyrocketed to the
top of the League of Legends subreddit
and exploded across social media the
community dubbed it the dunzo manifesto
immediately cementing its place in a
league Amim history cyrus teased his own
version of the dunzo manifesto when he
retired but eventually decided against
it alas we will never see the dyrus
papyrus so [ __ ] funny
and CLG memed on it too when their
former ADC sub yuna wrote his own dunzo
manifesto which the team submitted to
the league's subreddit from their own
account but if you peel back the memes
and the drama the letter stands as a
unique if very biased look as the NA LCS
at a time when it was still growing into
what it would become today there were
probably a lot of factors that
Leadville in frustration he ran away
from home he put an education at
Berkeley on hold and he was locked into
a contract with CLG that he really
didn't want to be in towards the end but
the lack of infrastructure couldn't have
helped things either CLG had chosen a
coach who was working remotely from
South Korea and the huge support staff
that modern franchised LCS teams have
today were a pipe dream back then links
letter was supposed to be this big mic
drop moment he wanted to expose the
problem with his former team and
teammates and he wanted to shine a light
on a side of League of Legends that the
community had never seen before however
his bias throughout the letter was
called out immediately now the problem
with this farewell letter it was riddled
with inconsistencies he'd say something
and then a paragraph or paragraph and a
half later you'd find him say another
sentence which didn't didn't fit in with
what he just said before it was like a
soap opera plot how extreme the opinions
were in this and the unkind the
characterization of these people yeah I
have no concern with link telling the
truth but when you tell it true from a
hundred percent your perspective
you're not taking account into how other
people feel about it and that
drastically changes the equation and he
knows that what he did is gonna make
people hate CG so what I see him be like
oh yeah it's a farewell letter no it's a
[ __ ] you letter all that considered one
would have expected doublelift to
respond with an equal amount of venom
after all he's made a name for himself
talking trash everyone else's trash and
mostly backing it up on the rest it's
gonna be the stuff in from devilish Hui
Jukes it will mayor gets one shot at
there the wind slash though it's not
gonna be enough double it gets the dual
instead double if the dress almost every
point in the seventeen page document
here invited a few of them but with
others peep flat out admitted he was
wrong and apologized
[Music]
CLG finished second during the 2015
summer regular season just after link
left and Team Liquid will take down
counter logic gaming for top spot in the
NA LCS summer split regular season and
then in the playoffs they went
undefeated against team impulses Emmys
and TSM in the finals counter logic
gaming fighting every season since there
has been one and now taking down team so
to be your truth
what check kids I mean I'm speechless
it's been years of blood sweat tears for
all of us
sorry my my throat's shot oh but it's
it's truly magical to be here thank you
in other words link left before the team
took off link helpful to find the
competitive landscape of the NA LCS
during his formative years but his
letter is how most people remember him
hindsight is 20/20 and link says that he
regrets how his time with CLG ended
[Music]
but it's hard not to wonder how long's
career would have turned out in the
current na LCS environment an
environment that has a lot more
structure and support for its players
nowadays link still streams sometimes
playing league of legends
sometimes like fortnight
but he's back on track to what he was
doing before his eSports career studying
at Berkeley blink has largely moved on
from eSports but his dunzo manifesto
will stand as a historical document from
an NA LCS that is hopefully long since
passed thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]